so here's a prediction if we get our
cities right we just might survive the
21st century we get them wrong and we're
done for cities are the most
extraordinary experiment in social
engineering that we humans have ever
come up with if you live in a city and
even if you live in a slum which 20% of
the world's urban population does you're
likely to be healthier wealthier better
educated and live longer than your
country cousins there's a reason why
three million people are moving to
cities every single week cities are
where the future happens first they're
open they're creative they're dynamic
they're Democratic they're cosmopolitan
they're sexy they're the perfect
antidote to reactionary nationalism but
cities have a dark side
they take up just 3% of the world's
surface area if they count for more than
75% of our energy consumption and they
emit 80 percent of our greenhouse gases
there are hundreds of thousands of
people who die in our cities every
single year from violence and millions
more who are killed as a result of car
accidents and pollution in Brazil where
I live we've got 25 of the 50 most
homicidal cities on the planet and a
quarter of our cities have chronic water
shortages and this in a country with 20%
of the known water reserves so cities
are dual edged part of the problem is
that apart from a handful of mega cities
in the West and the Far East we don't
know that much about the thousands of
cities in Africa in Latin America and
Asia where 90 percent of all future
population growth is set to take place
so why this knowledge gap well part of
the problem is that we still see the
world through the lens of nation-states
we're still locked in a 17th century
paradigm of parochial national
sovereignty and yet in the 1600s when
nation-states were really coming into
their own
less than 1% of the world's population
resided in this city today it's 54
percent and by 2050 will be closer to 70
percent so the world has changed we have
these 193 nation states but we have
easily as many cities that are beginning
to rival them in power and influence
just look at New York the Big Apple has
8.5 million people and an annual budget
of 80 billion dollars its GDP is 1.5
trillion which puts it higher than
Argentina and Australia Nigeria and
South Africa it's roughly 40,000 police
officers
means that it has one of the largest
police departments in the world rivaling
all but the largest nation states but
cities like New York or San Paulo or
Johannesburg or Dhaka or Shanghai
they're punching above their weight
economically but below their weight
politically and that's gonna have to
change cities are gonna have to find
their political voice if we want to
change things now I want to talk to you
a little bit about the risks that cities
are facing some of the big mega risks
I'm also going to talk to you briefly
about some of the solutions I'm going to
do this using a big data visualization
that was developed with Carnegie
Mellon's create lab and my Institute
along with many many others and I want
you to first imagine the world not as
made up of nation-states that has made
up of cities what you see here is every
single city with a population of a
quarter million people or more now
without going the technical detail the
red or the circle the more fragile that
city is and the blue of the circle the
more resilient fragility occurs when the
social contract comes unstuck and we
tend to see is a convergence of multiple
kinds of risks income inequality poverty
youth unemployment different issues
around violence even exposure to
droughts cyclones and earthquakes now
obviously some cities are more fragile
than others the good news if there is
any is that fragility is not a permanent
condition some cities that were once the
most fragile cities in the world
like boat with Don Columbia or Ciudad
Juarez in Mexico I have now fallen more
around the national average the bad news
is is it frigidly is deepening
especially in those parts of the world
that are most vulnerable in North Africa
the Middle East in South Asia and
Central Asia there were seeing fragility
rising way be off scales we've ever seen
before
now when cities become too fragile they
can collapse tip over and fail and when
that happens we have explosive forms of
migration refugees there are more than
22 million refugees in the world today
more than at any other time since the
Second World War now there's not one
refugee crisis there are multiple
refugee crises and contrary to what you
might read the news the vast majority of
refugees aren't fleeing from poor
countries to wealthy countries they're
moving from poor cities into even poorer
cities often cities nearby
now every single dot on this map
represents an agonizing story of
struggle and survival but I want to
briefly tell you about what's not on
that map and that's internal
displacement there are more than 36
million people who've been internally
displaced around the world these are
people living in refugee like conditions
but lacking the equivalent international
protection and assistance and to
understand their plight I want to zoom
in briefly on Syria Syria suffered one
of the worst droughts in its history
between 2007 and 2010 more than 75% of
its agriculture 85% of its livestock
were wiped out and in the process over a
million people moved into cities like
Aleppo Damascus and Homs as food prices
began to rise
you also had equivalent levels of social
unrest I mean the regime of President
Assad began cracking down you had an
explosion of refugees you also had over
six million entry displaced people many
of whom went on to become refugees and
they didn't just move to neighboring
countries like Jordan or Lebanon or
Turkey they also moved up north towards
Western Europe see over 1.4 million
Syrians made the perilous journey
Mediterranean and up through Turkey to
find their way into two countries
primarily Germany and Sweden now climate
change not just droughts but also sea
level rise is probably one of the most
severe existential threats that cities
face that's because two-thirds of the
world's cities are coastal over 1.5
billion people live in low-lying flood
prone coastal areas now what you see
here is a map that shows sea level rise
in relation to changes in temperature
climate scientists predict that we're
going to see anywhere between three and
thirty feet of sea level rise this side
of the century and it's not just low
island nation states that are going to
suffer
Kirra baths or the maldives or the
Solomons of sri lanka and they will
suffer but also massive cities like
dhaka like Hong Kong like Shanghai
cities of 10 20 30 million people or
more are literally going to be wiped off
the face of this earth they're gonna
have to adapt or they're gonna die I
want to thank you also all the way over
to the West because this isn't just a
problem in Asia or Africa or Latin
America this is a problem also in the
West this is Miami many of you know
Miami is one of the wealthiest cities in
the United States it's also one of the
most flood-prone that's been made
painfully evident by natural disasters
throughout 2017 but Miami's built on
porous limestone a swamp and there's no
way any kind of flood barrier is gonna
keep the water from seeping in and as we
scroll back we look across the Caribbean
and along the Gulf we begin to realize
that those cities that have suffered
worse from natural crises port-au-prince
New Orleans Houston as severe and as
awful as those situations have been
they're a dress rehearsal for what's to
come now no city's an island every city
is connected to its rural hinterland in
complex ways often in relation to the
production of food I want to take you to
the northern part of the Amazon in
Rideau Nia this is one of the world's
largest terrestrial carbon sinks
processing millions of carbon every
single year what you see here is a
single road over a 30 year period and
either side you see land being cleared
for pasture for cattle but also for soy
and sugar production you're seeing
deforestation on
massive scale the red area here implies
a net loss of force over the last 14
years the blue if you could see it
there's not much implies has been an
incremental gain now as grim and gloomy
as a situation is and it is there is a
little bit of hope see the Brazilian
government from the National to the
state the municipal level has also
deduced whole range alas of parks and
protected areas and well not perfect and
not always limiting encroachment they
have served to tamp back deforestation
the same applies not just in Brazil but
all across the Americas into the United
States Canada and around the world so
let's talk about solutions
despite climate denial at the highest
levels cities are taking action
you know when the u.s. pulled out of the
Paris climate agreement hundreds of
cities in the United States and
thousands more around the world double
down on their climate commitments
and when the White House cracked down on
so-called undocumented migrants and
sanctuary cities hundreds of cities and
counties and states sit up in defiance
and refused to enact that order so
cities are and can take action but we're
going to see we're going to see we're
going to need to see a lot more of it
especially in the global south
you see parts of Africa and Latin
America are urbanizing before they
industrialized
they're growing at three times the
global average in terms of their
population and this is pretty enormous
strain on infrastructure and services
now there is a golden opportunity it's a
small opportunity but a golden one in
the next 10 to 20 years to really start
designing in principles of resilience
into our cities there's not one single
way of doing this but there are a number
of ways that are emerging and I've
spoken with hundreds of urban planners
of development specialists of architects
and civic activists and a number of
recurring principles keep coming out and
I just want to pass on six first cities
need a plan and a strategy to implement
it I mean it sounds crazy but the vast
majority of the world's cities don't
actually have a plan or a vision they're
too busy putting out daily fires to
think ahead strategically I mean every
city wants to be creative
happy livable resilient who doesn't the
challenge is how do you get there and
urban governance plays a key role you
could do worse and take a page from the
book of Singapore in 1971 Singapore set
a 50 year urban strategy and renews it
every five years what Singapore teaches
us is not just the importance of
continuity but also the critical role of
autonomy and discretion cities need the
power to be able to issue debt to raise
taxes to zone effectively to build
affordable housing what cities need is
nothing less than a devolution
revolution and this is going to require
renegotiating the terms the contract
with the nation-state second you got to
go green cities already leading global
decarbonization efforts they're
investing in congestion pricing schemes
and climate reduction the mission
targets and biodiversity and parks and
bikeways and walkways and everything in
between there's extraordinary menu of
options they have to choose from one of
the great things that cities are already
investing heavily in renewables in solar
and wind not just in North America but
especially in Western Europe and parts
of Asia there are more than 8,000 cities
right now in the world today with solar
plants there are 300 cities that are
declared complete energy autonomy one of
my favorite stories comes from Midian
which invested in a municipal
hydroelectric plant which definitely
service its local needs but allows a
city to sell access energy back onto the
national grid and it's not alone there
are thousand other cities just like it
third invest in integrated and multi-use
solutions you know the most successful
cities are those that are invest in
solutions that don't solve just one
problem but they solve multiple problems
take the case of integrated public
transport when done well rapid bus
transit light rail bikeways walkways
boat ways these can dramatically reduce
emissions and congestion they can do a
lot more than that they can improve
public health they can reduce dispersion
they can even increase safety a great
example this comes from Seoul
you see Seoul's population doubled over
the last 30 years but the footprint
barely changed how well 75 percent of
Seoul's residents get to work using
what's been described is one of the most
extraordinary public transport systems
in the world and so leads to the car
country next fourth bill densely but
also sustainably you know the death of
all cities is the sprawl cities need to
know how to build resilient Lee but also
a way this inclusive this is a picture
right here of dallas-fort worth and what
you see is its population also doubled
over the last 30 years but as you can
see it's spread into edge cities and
suburbia as far as the eye can see
you see cities need to know when not to
build so it's not to reproduce urban
sprawl and slums of downward
accountability the problem with that
Fort Worth is just 5% of its residents
get to work using public transport 595
percent used cars which partly explains
why it's got some of the longest
commuting times in North America
Singapore by contrast got it right it
built vertically and built in affordable
housing to booth
v steel the smartest cities are nicking
pilfering stealing left right and center
they don't have time to waste they need
to Morris technology today and they're
gonna leapfrog to get there this is New
York but it's not just New York that's
doing a lot of stealing its Singapore
its Seoul it's Midian the urban
Renaissance is only going to be enabled
when cities start boring from one
another and finally work in global
coalition's you know there are more than
200 inner city coalition's in the world
today there are more city coalition's
and there are coalition's for nation
states just take a look at the global
Parliament of Mayors set up by the late
Ben barber who's driving an urban rights
movement or consider the c40 a marvelous
network of cities that has gathered
thousands together to deliver clean
energy or look at the world agonic forum
which is developing smart city protocols
or the honda resilient cities initiative
which is leading a resilience revival
Ecklie
you see LG metropolis these are the
movements of a future what they all
realize is that when cities work
together they can amplify their voice
not just on the national stage but on
the global stage and with a voice comes
potentially a vote and then maybe even a
veto
when nation-states default on their
national sovereignty cities have to step
up they can't wait and they don't need
to ask for permission they can exert
their own sovereignty they understand
that the local and the global have
really truly come together that we live
in a global local world and we need to
adjust our politics accordingly and as I
travel around the world my meet mayors
and civic leaders I'm amazed by the
energy enthusiasm and effectiveness they
bring to their work they're pragmatists
they're problem solvers they're Peres
diplomats
and in this moment of extraordinary
international uncertainty when our
multilateral institutions are paralyzed
and our nation states are in retreat
cities and their leaders are our new
21st century visionaries they deserve
know they have a right to a seat at the
table thank you
[Applause]
[Music]